las vegas his oldest freestanding bar
celebrates 70 years of serving locals
and tourists in our community of course
we're talking about atomic liquors in
east fremont madison kimbrough stopped
by this evening to hear why it's so
special
you have people come and visit you from
out of town and they're like let's go to
the strip and as a local you tend to say
how about we don't atomic is the great
way to get out of that give them the
little history to her and have a good
time las vegas oldest freestanding bar
atomic liquors turns 70. and starting
friday they are hosting a three-day
celebration in honor of this historic
gem located in downtown las vegas and
originally named virginia's cafe the now
bar opened in the 1940s general manager
christopher gutierrez says the original
owners enjoyed hosting cocktail parties
so much that they changed their
establishment into a liquor store with a
more bar-like feel thus getting their
liquor license in 1952. so how did they
get the atomic name we were named atomic
because of our famed uh
watch parties our nuclear watch parties
that would occur from the roof in the
early 50s at the test site right over
there to the north and you want to talk
about history here is a bottle of old
crow bourbon that dates back to the
1970s originally found when the bar was
under renovation described as an escape
from the strip atomic lickers has
welcomed iconic figures into their bars
throughout the decades including the rat
pack barbara streisand clint eastwood
and several more
so cheers to 70 years